hey youtubers its charlie happy Black
Friday so this is gonna be my Jessica
Jones episode 9 through 12 video
everything through beginning of sin bin
all the way through Jessica Jones vs.
Luke Cage so here we go just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen through
Jessica Jones on episode 12 yet but one
of my favorite episodes was number 9
because we learned so much about
killgrave we learned that he was abused
as a child and essentially left to fend
on his own like they just left him on
the street his parents took off they
were so afraid to be fair to his mother
she had that giant burned from the iron
hunter face to show exactly what had
happened but you know he says well I
didn't know what was going on I was a
little child so if he's a psychopath
that has zero empathy for everyone else
like he has no idea what everyone else
is feeling because he's never able to
tell whether or not people are doing
what he asks because they want to or
because of his powers he didn't make it
seem like as an adult he could choose to
not use his powers on people but just to
use some doctor who logic the doctor
lies I'm guessing that it's a passive
ability that he doesn't really have
control over it just it's always on the
way his father explains it like the the
origin of kilgrave's so to speak is that
he had a degenerative brain condition
they introduced a very special
experimental virus and even though that
fixed him the side effect was is that he
started to emit this virus that just
caused everyone to listen to whatever
suggestions he gave them now here's the
deal because eventually he tries to amp
his powers up there's a degree of
proximity involved and it's not psychic
he actually has to speak the words which
is why they used the headphones in later
episodes so think of him as being like a
bio computer hacker like if you were to
walk by him in a crowd there's nothing
you could do to stop him from uploading
the virus to you but as long as you
can't hear what he says he cannot input
commands so you're still okay to go so
it's not so much the virus need to worry
about its him giving you commands while
you're affected by the virus and I know
a lot of people think that that person
by the club is stuck forever staring at
that fence because he did tell him that
when his powers were enhanced as long as
it wore off within like a week or so he
probably would not die from dehydration
you can go without food a lot longer
than you can go without water but he's
probably okay he probably survived isn't
it crazy that like all throughout the
series even in the earlier episodes how
Jessica runs into people who aren't able
to fulfill their command
so they just go crazy like Patti trying
to put the bullet in her head
so jessica has to like literally put the
bullet in her mouth see it's in your
head you can stop now
you guys can let me know if you agree or
not though don't you feel like the last
couple of episodes start to get more and
more graphic like the stuff the kilgrave
does like the way he kills his father in
the way he dealt with the other two
dudes that he stole the apartment from
the thousand cuts to jeryn hogarth did
feel like it was justified like she
definitely got what she deserved
but that whole storyline felt a little
contrived like it was only there to give
him a way to get out they set her up to
be like okay I'm gonna turn this off and
release him then it all goes sideways
kilgrave ends up killing his mother
which was also one of the more graphic
killings stabbed yourself for every year
that you left me alone kilgrave getting
out will Simpson burning down all the
evidence it all feels like the story's
just trying to give Jessica more reasons
to have to kill kilgrave like they won't
have the evidence against him because it
all got burnt down so they can't
prosecute him and kilgrave's power start
to go off the scale so he's able to
mind-control people at great distances I
know everybody's asking about IgH in
officer Simpson because he's definitely
nuke from the comics he's kind of like
an early prototype
but because we have the Punisher in the
Netflix universe I'm not gonna call him
The Punisher he is one of the few actors
that I did not like in Jessica Jones I
feel like his performance was just
completely wood
he worked way better in the early
episodes when he was just the sex buddy
which is the person for padding to say
hey you know last night was fun but shut
up don't talk the reason they're seating
this IgH stuff like you know connecting
all these enhanced people to this IgH
company the pills jessica jones kilgrave
the reason like they're trying to
connect this is because they're trying
to create more mythology that they can
dig into in season 2 like officer
Simpson says he's repaying with his old
group and it looks like this Hydra type
organization they're very organized
we're gonna do good things together son
they answered zero questions about that
so that's all season 2 stuff just just
consider it off in the distance but the
Simpson character or nuke ever you want
to think of them is a villain from the
daredevil comics but he also crosses
over with a lot of Captain America
comics to think of him as a more
sinister version of The Punisher he
wants to do good he wears the flag but
he just goes completely overboard he's
just out of control the organization in
the comics that nuke is tied to is
called the weapon Plus program you could
thank Grant Morrison
that it's like the US government
responding to the potential threat of a
mutant human war so it tries to create
its own super soldiers well Simpson is
just part of that the characterization
kind of comes through and the the
Jessica Jones version of the character
like he's trying to kill kilgrave
because he's like we can't prosecute him
he's too dangerous but he's just so over
the top nuts that he completely kills
everyone else because he thinks they're
gonna stop him from killing killgrave so
I'll say yeah like of any of the
storylines that I didn't really like
during Jessica Jones I didn't like the
will Simpson stuff I feel like they just
needed like a version of kilgrave for
Patsy to overcome and that was actually
the fun part when she takes the pills
who else thought that that's what they
were headed the minute she took the
pills from will the first time she ran
afoul of him after he came back on the
pills like she took some stuck him in
her pocket he's like oh yeah she's
definitely gonna take those she almost
dies they bring her back and she's just
like hell yeah that was so amazing is
this what you feel like all the time
Jessica so just expect more crazy Patsy
stuff like that in season 2 she was a
lot of fun I love the patsy character
I'm so glad that it was hurt and not
Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel very awesome character in
the Marvel Universe but I yeah i think
she'll work just a lot better in the
movies than she would in a TV show like
this then we got to talk about Luke Cage
under kilgrave's control it was so fun
watching him bulrush him and killgrave
just had to like put his hand up what do
you want with me I want to kill you
take a bloody number we also learned
that Jessica is able to severely injure
Luke with the shotgun blast to the head
now he has super strong skin but his
internal organs are not super strong
they're just normal internal organs so
if they needed to operate on his
internal organs they could also go in
through his mouth if they had to but no
this Netflix version of Luke Cage is
completely normal
underneath his skin it's just is the
skin it's just this hard layer so if you
ever wanted to take him down you know
use bash his head really hard against
the curb if you never read World War
Hulk whenever Hulk comes back from
Planet Hulk just wanting to destroy
every hero in the Marvel Universe in
order to take Wolverine down because
Wolverine has a healing factor the only
way Hulk can stop him is by bashing his
head so hard that it turns his brain
into mush so Wolverine is incapacitated
while his brain regenerates but if he
felt like the episode started to drag
towards the middle of the run I feel
like these last couple of episodes is
where the
she gets cranked up like between
episodes nine and twelve I'll say
episode nine is probably still my
favorite now I'm gonna do a separate
video for episode thirteen but if you
guys want you can ask me questions about
that too like the way it ends season two
stuff I'm gonna do an episode 13 video
and then I'll do a season two
predictions video like you know first
storylines that I think they should do
or characters I think they should bring
in they'll let me know in the comments
what was your favorite thing from this
last block of episodes and what do you
think is going on with this IgH group do
you think they're connected to Hydra or
do you think they're their own separate
thing my thoughts with the IgH because
they they don't really tie into a
specific comic book group is that
they're gonna be this separate entity
that they might be able to loosely
connect to Hydra but they probably won't
there was this line in a recent agents
of shield episode if you haven't
watching it where they say Hydra is a
very complex organization and the idea
is that Hydra is a secret organization
that has its own secret organizations
inside of it that Hydra members don't
know about so IgH could be one of those
but if like everyone in ten person in a
place of authority is connected to Hydra
then IgH probably has some loose ties to
it and just to clarify they haven't
picked Jessica Jones up for season two
officially yet but I would expect an
announcement within the next couple of
weeks usually usually they wait just a
little while in case you guys haven't
seen it I posted a Batman V Superman
video you can click here to watch that
learn all about the next teaser that's
coming and you can click here for the
Captain America civil war trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you